so let's read this first story let's
just jump right into it we got nbc news
reporting
texas democrats flee state in effort to
block
gop-backed voting restrictions the
lawmakers are on their way to washington
to advocate for federal voting rights
legislation
risking arrest by leaving during the
special session i just want to point out
very quickly
i love how it's always framed in the
media voting restrictions
voting suppression you give them an inch
to take a mile absolutely
and one of the things you have to
understand is if you go back to april of
last year
eric holder who is the chairman of the
national democratic redistricting
committee wrote an op-ed piece in time
magazine
and the title of that op-ed piece was
how coronavirus should permanently
change elections in america
and what did they lay out they lay out
the fact that they were going to use
universal mail and ballots which is
different from absentee balloting
absentee balloting is a control
mechanism uh
you have to send in like in the military
you have to send in requests for the
ballot and it's sent back to you
controlled
absolutely but they're talking about
just flooding the zone with ballots that
are out there and one of the things that
we have
evaded in harris county which is the
largest county
in the state of texas third largest in
united states of america is around
houston
the county clerk down there wanted to
mail out 2.7 million ballots
against a voter registration roll that
had never been reviewed
wow and i think if 2.7 million ballots
had just gotten out there in texas which
donald trump only won by 620 000
now that's the type of thing that they
want to have they want to have 24-hour
voting
uh in texas so i guess we're going to
have polling locations at waffle house
and denny's and things of that nature
unchecked nobody should be watching
nobody watching and then the other thing
that they want is curbside voting now
curbside vote in texas constitution
is very clearly defined if you are
you know unable to get out of your car
you go to a polling location
and you arrange for your ballot to be
submitted there at that polling location
they just want curbside voting anywhere
as a matter of fact
that exact same person chris hollins set
up nine different curbside voting
locations
all across harris county now those are
the type of things that we're trying to
eliminate from happening
signature verification stop having poll
watchers republican poll watchers being
bullied and not allowed to go in
and do what they're supposed to do
watching the the ballot county process
but what is so funny tim because you
know i just flew up here
uh to tech to to dc i was on an american
airlines plane i had to wear a mask and
everything
but there's a picture of these democrats
flying up here on the private jets and
guess who's sitting on the front row of
one of those private jets without a mask
my state representative retta bowers wow
throwing up the peace signs so i really
do feel represented thanks a lot
real quick um i also bet to get on that
plane you had to show an id
i bet they didn't oh no you oh i had to
show an idea
right yeah were you able to board the
plane curbside uh no i was not able to
board playing curbside and i had to be
on time
it was not a 24-hour window for me to
board the plane did the plane
come to your house unannounced without
you asking for it and then offer you a
ride
i don't really have a good runway see
it's funny i mean obviously i'm being a
little bit facetious but
with the with these voting restrictions
it eliminates a lot of the security
basic basic security curbside i mean
when i uh during the the primaries when
i was in new jersey
i got a mail-in ballot for somebody who
did not live at my house
and i don't i don't know why it was a
legit full ballot and then
what am i supposed to do with it it's
not mine i don't i don't know it's
election mail i don't want to touch it
yeah but when you combine that with
ballot harvesting oh yeah
and and the next thing you know someone
comes around and picks up that ballot
and then it is actually officially
counted
see that's what the left wants and the
other thing that i find so interesting
is that these texas democrats who are
really obstructing the legislative
process in the lone star state
they're up here talking about more
federal control of elections
well the constitution does not give the
federal government any enumerated power
it has not delegated any power for them
to
run elections in the united states of
america there's no centralized control
but
that's one of the socialist tennis is
nationalizing production
not just economic production but also
all we see uh
elections they have to do it one grain
at a time they can't just come out but
this
uh this hr one that they're trying to do
federally it effectively nationalizes
it does elections and the point this is
lost on democrats the craziest things
because it's not a republican issue it's
basic american civics
that each state has the senators
represent a state to the federal
government because we are a union of
sovereign states free and independent
states that's what the declaration says
so they each state has their election
and determines who they want to submit
as electors
yeah they want they want i don't i don't
know where this myth or this lie comes
from but you have a very large
uneducated population of people
who genuinely believe a national popular
vote makes sense because they don't
understand that we are a united
states of america absolutely and it's a
representative democracy so
now also when you read hr1 what does hr
1 says hr 1 says that there will be
no picture id anywhere in the united
states of america
really and there will be no voter
registration rule review
anywhere in the united states of america
really that they're going to be
universal mail and ballots that's going
to be the standard
all across the united states of america
so basically we're just going to mail
out ballots all over the place
and uh people can fill them out like you
just talked about it's it's it's
it's like treating our elections like a
raffle you know i don't know you got to
take us got a number on it right
congratulations you won the prize well
you know what's so amazing tim
is and you know ian and i were talking
previously you know the times that i
served in combat
i was in combat trying to help people
establish voting
systems that now are probably better
than ours i mean
you know i would you know everyone
remember the purple finger
well now i mean i don't think we have
any way of really determining who's been
voting
where were you when you were trying to
set up the voting system that was in
iraq i mean
in iraq and then also in afghanistan we
were trying to implement these
democratic principles and and
fundamentals and now here
in the united states of america we're
eroding and undermining
our democratic principles and
fundamentals we used to be the gold
standard
show me another country in the world
that says we're just going to mail out
ballots
yeah without checking without checking
that to me is absolutely insane
well it is insane but that's how you get
to one part of control which is exactly
what the progressive socialists want in
america
it's it's you know i look at you you
want your voting system to be a
well-oiled machine
where each part of that process is
mappable you can track this piece goes
to this piece to this piece to this
piece
so when the ballot comes out we know
where the ballot came from we know who
sent it we know who got it and why
whether they went in person or they got
an absentee ballot which has that chain
of custody
now it seems like they're just trying to
turn into into a splotch they can't
track where things are going you can't
you know we we had that election i think
it was in north jersey where they found
a big
bundle of ballots all just tied together
absentee ballots
and that it made no mathematical sense
so this caused a federal judge to say
do over that's that we can't have that
how are we supposed to have confidence
in a system well you can't and
and you know this is what has happened
it's not coincidental
so at the same time that we're trying to
nationalize elections
and not have any picture id no signature
verification
on these mail and ballots we've got an
open borders policy
we've got hundreds of thousand people
flowing into the state of texas
or planes that are all of a sudden
showing up in the middle of the night in
tennessee
well you know before we get into that i
want to mention something about that
you know those people get represented in
the electoral vote regardless of whether
or not they cast a vote
that's because the the left does not
believe that the census should be based
upon
citizenship they want the census to be
based upon
numbers and so they're flooding it in
because they want to have what
they want to have those districts that
will lean more so toward
the democrats i think it was tucker
carlson he was saying that democrats
want illegal immigrants because they
want votes something that affects i
think it was tucker
and the media went nuts it's funny when
you can tell when someone's over target
when they're like ah
he's a racist and a white supremacist
and uh he's technically
right but he misses one piece of it
democrats don't need illegal immigrants
to go and vote
they just need a census yes so in
california i think it was
um i think it was maybe heritage they
said that california gets about one
extra electoral vote because of the
amount of illegal immigration in the
state
the illegal immigrants are counted on
the census uh congressional seats with
an apportioned based on the census
number
not the amount of citizens and then you
get electoral votes based on how many
reasons think about what you just said
what just happened in this last round of
the census
california lost an electoral seat and
new york i think too right
and new york too and guess who picked up
two texas
wow nice right when you have the open
borders and everything that's happening
and why did you see them all remember
they pushed off the census they pushed
off the results
and as soon as joe biden gets in was one
of the first things he does by
unconstitutionally by executive order
opens up the borders
and now we have the flood of people that
are coming in to be fair though
california's got
some pretty open border policies i mean
they're offering up health care to
illegal immigrants under a certain age
so
you know they ended up losing i think
because of the mass exodus but i also
i'll also throw this out there as well
taxes did gain but i think people are
fleeing california into texas
they are and there are two types of
people that are fleeing not just
california but illinois
new york new jersey coming into texas
and other successful red states you have
those people that
have given up they say i'm tired of it
i'm a conservative i want to go
somewhere where i can live under
conservative principles and policies
but then you also have the folks that
are part of the transplanted workforce
when you pick up and you move a
corporation or business
like we've seen state farm liberty
mutual toyota north america elon musk
coming out of these places and the key
thing is that we've got to convey to
these presidents and ceos
tell your folks that if they want to
continue to vote
like that stay but don't come here to
texas which you're trying to come here
because you want to benefit from our
economic policies
and the next thing you know it's i call
it the locust effect
because california used to be a strong
red state oh yeah until like what 92 i
think
absolutely look what happened yeah have
you ever seen that comic somebody made
where joe rogan
he's walking from california to texas
and he's carrying uh he's got a travel
bag that says liberal policies on it
and then there's like a cowboy in texas
like whoa don't bring that with you yeah
absolutely you know and a lot of people
down in texas will say
we need to have a border wall not just
on the southern border but also on the
west side of texas as well and
we need to have people turn in that blue
car and we can give them a red card
yeah you got to vote this way i mean i
moved out of philly and we're now
basically in west virginia
and i've got a bunch of people here like
you know i went to a store it was really
funny
because they were talking about oh these
liberals are moving out here and you can
tell
and then i laugh and i'm like yeah i'm
one of i moved from philly and there's
eyes just like oh yeah they squint
and then i went don't worry don't worry
i'm not gonna vote for any of their you
know people because i'm i'm jaded and
they went oh okay all right well vote
republican and i was like
if they're good if they're good i'm not
i'm not playing those games anymore you
know
well you got to vote on principles and i
think that that's one of the things that
you're looking at
uh that is happening in the country is
that it is no longer so much about
political parties it's about your
principles and values it's the ideology
it's the principle
the philosophy of governance because you
can have republicans that are
progressives
you can have republicans that believe in
big government spending and things of
that nature as a matter of fact
the united states chamber of commerce
supports open borders why
because they want cheap labor and that
still hurts people too so you got one
political party that wants
because of quote-unquote votes or to
skew the census and the population then
you have another
political party that wants the cheap
labor this this is something that i was
just thinking about recently because uh
the southern poverty law center called
me a reactionary yeah which is funny
because i'm like actually kind of a
reformer which is not
you know reactionaries want to keep the
old system and i'm like no i think we
got to make a lot of changes to that
system
i just don't want to burn it down and i
thought it was pretty funny because
policy wise
you know i'm thinking about the
political compass and like whether i'm
you know i'm like what are my positions
and so i actually
on the political compass i'm fairly left
libertarian but i think there's
something that easily
like you can easily understand this uh i
think you and i like
america the constitution we like the
country like our borders
like our freedom and there's like a
difference in policy ideas but the
interesting thing about this is
if i say something like i'm actually in
favor of a basic universal health care
system with private insurance
that doesn't mean left anymore unless
you hate america it's i know it might
sound a little bit hyperbolic
or exaggerated to say like this oh
liberals hate america but i mean think
about this
when it comes to progressives how many
of the people do you see on tv saying
they want universal health care will
also proudly wave the american flag
and say this this country was found on
an amazing on great principles that
plenty of the seeds of freedom
they're not going to say those things
they're not and think about what we saw
happen
on independence day you know coming from
maxine waters coming from you know cory
bush who
i don't understand how corey bush is in
the united states house of
representatives you got a picture
downstairs in your basement
of david dorn yeah we do and and that
was the police officer that was killed
because of the
violent uh protests that corey bush led
murderous riots a murderous riots and
now she's sitting in the united states
house of representatives a member of the
house judiciary committee
but corey bush stood there and said that
blacks in america still aren't free
and i'm thinking okay uh i was born in a
blacks only hospital in 1961.
how am i not free but when they continue
to spew that
rhetoric and you still have people that
buy into it they listen to it
then they start to believe yeah you know
i'm not free i'm owed something i need
reparations i need all of these things
and that's why like i said last time a
show like yours is so important to get
this message out
especially to the millennial generations
in in your in your uh i don't want to go
too much into this because i want to
talk about this in depth but you uh you
showed us your
your announcement video for governorship
and you included the names of several
black men
who are like pioneers and founders in
texas of i think texas a
m yeah uh state senator matthew gaines
who
uh former slave but ended up being a
state center in texas and
co-founded texas a m university in
prairie view a m
g t ruby texas state uh house
representatives
uh and then the very first black
chairman of the republican party of
texas which was founded by 150 black men
norris ray cooney
a houston a galveston businessman those
men
have they prove anybody with hard work
can succeed and they have accomplished
more than than all of these progressive
racist activists will ever accomplish
yeah you're absolutely right and see
what they also prove is that
they were not defined by what they were
they were defined by what they would
become
and what they did absolutely their
legacy that's the leg thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you